did you improvise on scrubs often yeah a
ton
and that's a credit to bill i i i gave
him for for
for being tough on me but i i should end
by saying uh i love him to death and
he's one of my best friends in the world
but as a as a as a um
you know a nod to him he was very very
free with letting us play around and a
lot of people's
favorite stuff came from us just being
you know so close
and silly and the thing about scrub is
it created such a safe environment
you know when we when a normal when
you're going to a job as an as an actor
a normal situation every you know it's
like first day of school you're nervous
you want to do a good job you want to
seem like you're good at what you do and
and you're like you don't want to put
yourself out there too much you don't
want to
overstep or be too big or whereas
after the family that was created in
scrubs and i'm sure you felt this with
your shows too
is that it creates an environment where
there's like
there's a net underneath the the the
line and you can
you can always go crazy and do whatever
comes to your mind and just be
fully self-expressed and out of that
safety
a lot of it will be too silly and not
make sense but some of it will be
will be gems and a lot of that happened
on scrubs who is the one i mean
i'm sure it's gonna be hard to answer
because you don't want to say one person
but who's the one guy or girl
who made you laugh the most it's just so
flynn i can say it everyone everyone on
scrubs would probably say the same
answer
neil flynn who played the janitor he's a
hilarious uh improv
uh comedian and and uh
a genius uh funny person do you remember
a day where you just there's times in
the script where we just say
and then neil makes up something
[Laughter]
because the writers would be like
midnight and they'd be like i i don't
know whatever we're going to say he's
going to beat anyway so just have him
come up with a punch line
it would say like parentheses neil makes
up something funny here
and he always would times ten dude he's
he's
he's the most quick-witted actor i've
ever performed what's the one thing that
you remember where you just couldn't
stop laughing like they it was getting
up people were getting pissed because we
they couldn't move on
there's a bit and you can look at this
up on the gag rails on youtube but
there's a bit where the janitors
wanted me to wear his wife had made me
short shorts
made of the scrubs material and he
wanted me to wear them
and i was like i'm not i'm a doctor i
can't wear
short shorts to work and he said but my
wife and this is all stuff he was making
up he's like but my wife
put a lot of work into these she doesn't
have the good lord didn't
bless my wife with all 10 fingers she
was just
born with pointer and thumb pinky
and um he then proceeded to show how she
made the short shorts using pointer and
thumb mickey and
i couldn't get through it and that's
just him being silly and crazy